hello christ-like followers and Jews and
Muslims and whatever race you are
I'm Greg Alva with the lovely Jimmy
Mikado which other but shot Oh Jimmy you
know I was reading a book that was
saying one of the best ways to like
become friends with people is to
remember their names well yeah I've done
that today Jimmy came on the channel
many men was a little sick right now
Jimmy came on the channel many many
months ago he was a fan of the channel
he met me at my apartment then I was
like sure he could come on he has a new
channel up with that he does with his
brother called death and terror death
and terror death and terror I watched
one of the videos some pretty disturbing
stuff you guys got to go watch it it's
pretty just think that's pretty
interesting stuff Jimmy's back with me
now first guests of 2017 is this
handsome beautiful man over here young
single ready to Wingull Dingell out
we're gonna watch today the passengers
weird trigger by Aldo Jones Aldo Jones
himself sent this over to me and I
promised Aldo Jones that when he sends a
video over I will get a guest on to
watch this but right now I'm just wanna
look at you you got like these amazing
features you're like a Mexican James
Dean
[Music]
find this evening we're on a date very
nice
took you long enough so why did you give
up your life on earth
[Music]
[Music]
120 years hibernation means we'll wake
up in a new century but a year ago
everything changed
[Music]
so much jack
[Music]
something-something big boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this wasn't a have to tell me
Aquaman there's breezy we woke up early
do whatever you're gonna have us look
for some items yeah okay
Oh spider-man Oh God
that's what you look like Aldo holy crap
okay these were the same three items
that we had to find last time we're
gonna find these items okay and make
sure you donate to his patreon or PayPal
please donate I'm gonna donate five
bucks because that's all I can afford
have you seen the views this channel
gets lately there's no way gonna for
more than five bucks all right Jimmy
we're gonna have to find these these
weapons and last time I had to go to the
comments of this search for too long let
the search begin you have to find this
Batman symbol the Thor hammer and the
cap shield all right all right let's
place out music starting from the
beginning well I so much Jack Black I
felt like this kind of made the
passengers movie better with seeing that
this is part like his past as him in
Jurassic world
do you understand man this guy hides it
like to get the most random frame oh so
it's like very very hidden all right
it's hard to find all right we're at 2
seconds nothing there oh right there
what what is that what are you pointing
at that's a wheel was not the shield
where okay
that's just a red wheel down a wheel
you're my partner on this oh god I'm
[ __ ] I'm never gonna find this and you
thought that was the shield you know
what this is this is the feeling of you
and I giving up and going we're not
gonna find this as I feel that let's
just get in the comics this is ruining
it for everyone who wants to play the
game Thor's hammer 124
this is what we're even when people say
two boxes on these web boxes are we
talking about there's plenty of boxes do
you see it anywhere jimmy-jack okay
there's Captain America shield oh yeah
we found cap shield the battery is right
there it's so small hey man someone
found it that's crazy
ah [ __ ] you al those [ __ ] dude real
quick though real quick
Aldo I had no idea that's what you look
like I look like I could look like him
one day yeah you know I could totally
like him just grow my beard out a little
bit you got a pretty hot wife over there
you think he'd let us have a threesome
like me Aldo do you think like weird
[ __ ] goes down when they have sex I bet
you like weird [ __ ] goes that way just
has like things where you just pop out
of the room [ __ ] with her as he's
[ __ ] alright guys well please
subscribe to Aldo Jones you can
subscribe to this channel if you want
Jimmy Jimmy is a champ has a channel
with his brother called death and terror
where they do plenty of great video some
great list videos on there I actually
watched one and I'm gonna do a reaction
to another one that involves Filipinos
yes mouths have five dumbest things
about Filipinos is what he said that's
right he's racist no I'm not yeah you
are you're super racist sexist religious
means you don't like religion no no no
that's not the topic of the Filipinos
but he's also on instagram at Jamie a
Machado
parenthesis Jimmy he has the code on
there says he was dancing dancing he
says he'll never die that's a lie Craig
Alba that he put